we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this is the
funniest set of voicemails there's this
very very angry
trumpet named jimmy from philly and he
calls in every once in awhile but we
haven't heard from him for months and
every once in a while he will email me
and complain that he was not notified
about a live stream i was doing on
youtube or he was not notified about a
live stream i was doing on twitch or
something and it's like dude these are
just your settings i don't know what is
going on i don't know how tech-savvy you
are
he sent me two voicemails I've been
streaming on twitch.tv some of you may
know this and he sent me two consecutive
voicemails furious about different
elements of the twitch platform take a
listen to this week in Philly number one
I like to thank you for lying to me
about twitch being free for Amazon Prime
members yeah it's free for 30-days Davey
no that's it so listen the Prime
membership does not automatically renew
but every 30 days you can just sign up
again if you have Amazon Prime you can
subscribe to twitch.tv slash David
Pakman with twitch prime for free for 30
days and then when the 30 days are up
you just subscribe again for free
there's no you don't have to at any
point switch to a paid subscription if
you don't want to I think that's an
important little fact that you left yeah
yeah it's your honor and twitch is such
a peace issue that at least on a mobile
phone I mean with it was such a pain in
the ass to set it up and there and then
they try to actually like post a message
I mean is you kidding me
yeah it was just oh my god at the 5
minute I just I mean oh my [ __ ] no
wonder y'all we have 500 people at which
David 18 down which sucks who's paying
$12.99 a month for twitch David I don't
even know what Jimmy's talking about so
I think there's actually the potential
for a show here called tech time with
Jimmy from Philly
here he is continuing his tirade about
twitch David Jimmy from Chloe I'm so
pissed off this twitch app are you out
of your [ __ ] mind do you know how hard
it is to use a mobile phone on this [ __ ]
that I mean it's insane
it's literally insane
yeah $12.99 a month yeah yeah okay so
anyway there's Jimmy from Philly and
extraordinarily angry extraordinarily
furious but seriously folks twitch works
great the streams have been great we
take phone calls I will sometimes play
games of chess against people in the
audience I sometimes get crushed but
sometimes I win the twitch streams are
actually really great so follow me there
twitch TV slash David Pakman if you do
have Amazon Prime don't listen to Jimmy
it's free for as long as you want it to
be free 30 days at a time on the bonus
show today we will talk about if you are
stressed out by politics and I know more
and more people in my audience are I
will have some tips for how to continue
being engaged in politics but without
losing your cool we will also talk about
here in Massachusetts there has been a
four month ban on all vaping products
which is the toughest action that any
state has taken so far and I want to
talk about that as well as I have a lot
of friends in Massachusetts in sort of
tangentially in the vaping world either
in the cannabis industry or in different
industries that are related and my
facebook feed has been just blowing up
with this stuff and lastly the House has
passed a bill that would allow banks to
work with cannabis companies this has
been a big impediment actually to when
we talk about legalization of cannabis
you don't want to be working in a cash
situation if you are one of these
cannabis dispensaries or whatever else
because it makes you a target for
burglary it's just you want to be
accepting credit cards you want to be
putting money in the bank and that has
been something that has been limited for
federal banks to work with cannabis
related businesses and the House has
passed a bill we will see what happens
in the Senate that would make that much
easier all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show I welcome you to the
bonus show with open arms you can get
access instantly by signing up at join
pakman.com and or by becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
look forward to hearing from you there
and make sure if you have any thoughts
on today's program or anything else any
message you want to send me you can use
the voicemail line 24 hours a day
at two one nine two david p i'll speak
to you on the bonus show or on
tomorrow's program